a hive of activity during a nationwide
lockdown farmers burned a week to a
government procurement center in the
state of Uttar Pradesh it's a small
victory for brijesh admah who struggled
to harvest his crops this season without
the help of seasonal workers the father
of three says his family helped him cut
the crop and register to sell it to the
government
everyone faced a lot of problems with
the registration everything is shut so
how and where are we supposed to do it
we had no idea the children have some
education so they were able to do it on
their mobile phones the government is
sending electronic coupons to farmers
with a date and time to bring their
produce to the centers but in rural
areas many don't have smart phones and
internet connections to receive them
India's lockdown couldn't have come at a
worse time for farmers they're at their
busiest between April and June when
winter crops like wheat harvested and
the fields are prepared for summer crops
to be so without the technology needed
to register his crop or public transport
to take it to a government center or
private market the pain that but he's
worried about how he and his family will
survive we can't so the next crop as we
need money from this harvest to buy
seeds and fertilizers many farmers have
seen their fruit and vegetables go to
waste
despite farming being exempt from the
lockdown the restrictions on people's
movement and transport has led to supply
chains breaking down India has large
reserves of grains but economists say
extra stops of rice and wheat aren't
enough it's also about pulses and fruits
and vegetables and Indian diets are
already very poor the malnutrition rates
are very high so we need to ensure that
variety of food reaches people's plates
so both from a point of your food
security as well as keeping the economy
going it's very important that we
support agriculture and don't let it
collapse completely the government says
agriculture is functioning smoothly and
there are no shortages of food but many
reject that and with more than half of
India's workforce employed in
agriculture
X
say it must do more to help farmers and
secure the harvest for the next season
Elizabeth puranam al-jazeera Boleyn
shared author Pradesh